crypto I don't know why they do that are  you still in are you still like buying  in yeah really yeah I'm waiting for it  to go lower because I bought in already  what's funny my mom says I'm never wrong  what's funny yeah he's never wrong it is  going lower  it goes lower every time it goes lower I  put more in and what happens when it  hits zero and then I'm [ __ ]  there's no place you can storm there's  no place to go you know I mean like it's  not like there's not a president's house  there's not a guy my wife's gonna storm  a couple divorce attorneys offices I'll  tell you that if you found out how much  money I had in crypto she was like what  and I was like yeah hey we out here  let's see what happens